Générique
...
Musique intrigante
-Participer aux JO,
c'est incroyable.
C'est des émotions
qu'on ne vit pas ailleurs.
Il y a tellement de compétitions,
mais les JO,
c'est à part.
-J'essaye d'être prêt,
d'avoir mon mot à dire.
J'espère y être.
-Quand je pense
à la médaille olympique,
je ressens
des battements plus forts.
...
-Je suis complètement déterminée.
Je suis en mode guerrière
pour tout exploser.
...
Musique rythmée
-C'est une armée qui prend corps
qui se prépare à vivre
une de ses plus grandes batailles
pour gagner en France
une médaille olympique.
Sur la base aérienne 123
d'Orléans-Bricy,
ils sont 88 sportifs de haut niveau
de la Défense
à participer à un stage
d'acculturation militaire.
-Vas-y, ramasse !
Vite ! Vite !
-Du beau monde :
des champions d'Europe,
des champions
du monde, des médaillés
olympiques et paralympiques,
réunis pour renforcer
leur cohésion de groupe,
un indispensable
à la performance
sportive.
Cette immersion est l'occasion
pour les athlètes
de rencontrer
les aviateurs du Loiret,
de découvrir
leur environnement.
Parmi eux, il y a Mona.
Elle n'a que 21 ans, lorsque,
en 2011, elle perd sa jambe droite
dans un accident de la circulation.
-Le plus de poids
possible ?
-Exactement.
-OK.
-Pour se reconstruire,
elle va nager, nager vite,
nager fort,
jusqu'à enchaîner les performances.
Quelques années plus tard,
elle découvre
le handbike.
La nageuse se mue alors
en triathlète de talent
et décroche en 2022
le titre de championne
de France et d'Europe,
puis intègre l'armée de champions.
-On ne peut être
que solidaire des armées
qui sont en opération,
que ce soit à l'extérieur du pays
ou à l'intérieur,
pour défendre la France,
donc... Voilà.
Et puis, j'ai eu moi-même recours
à l'armée française
quand j'ai vécu au Liban
et qu'il y a eu la guerre.
J'ai pu être rapatriée
grâce à eux.
Quand on m'a appelée
et qu'on m'a dit
"Tu peux intégrer
l'armée de champions
"en tant que
sportive de haut niveau",
j'ai pas hésité une seconde
et j'ai dit oui tout de suite.
On partage
forcément
beaucoup de valeurs :
ne rien lâcher,
s'entraîner au quotidien pour,
le jour de la mission
ou de la compétition,
être au point, performant.
Ca, c'est des valeurs communes.
Après,
ils ont un métier
beaucoup plus risqué que le nôtre.
Ca, ça se respecte,
ne serait-ce que pour ça.
Ensuite, derrière,
c'est hisser le drapeau français
le plus haut
possible
et chanter la Marseillaise.
Musique solennelle
...
-Durant leur service,
ils consacrent
une partie de leur temps
à leur discipline favorite.
Au hasard de notre visite,
nous découvrons les rugbymen.
-Depuis la création
du bataillon de Joinville en 1956,
le ministère des Armées poursuit
une tradition de soutien
au sport de haut niveau français.
En 2014, la nouvelle politique
interministérielle
des sports donne plus
de souplesse et d'adaptabilité
dans le recrutement
et la gestion des sportifs
sur l'ensemble
des disciplines.
Ces athlètes qui forment
l'armée de champions
sont sous la responsabilité
du commissaire
aux sports militaires,
commandant le CNSD,
le Centre
national
des sports de la Défense,
situé à Fontainebleau.
-On les sélectionne
avec un ensemble d'acteurs,
heureusement.
D'abord, des experts sportifs
du ministère des Sports,
du Conseil national olympique
et sportif français, le CNOSF,
et puis, pour nos parathlètes,
son équivalent, le CPSF.
Et puis, une fois que
la partie sport...
En m'inspirant
de l'avis du ministère
et des instances
de gouvernance du sport,
avec des athlètes
qui sont sélectionnés
sur une liste ministérielle,
eh bien, je me penche
vers mes spécialistes militaires
du bataillon de Joinville
ou de l'Ecole interarmées
des sports.
Là, je regarde
leur profil.
Bien évidemment,
je contacte des gens
qui sont volontaires pour intégrer
nos valeurs militaires.
A partir de là,
après un entretien qu'on aura,
une lettre de motivation,
eh bien, on organise
une commission de recrutement,
d'avancement et de reconversion
de ces sportifs de haut niveau
et on les sélectionne.
Généralement, on en prend
1 sur 4 ou 1 sur 5.
Ce bataillon de Joinville,
aujourd'hui,
depuis 2021,
c'est 35 %
des médailles
des Jeux Olympiques
de Tokyo.
C'est 50 %, en paralympique
et en olympique,
des médailles d'or
des Jeux Olympiques
et Paralympiques de Tokyo.
Nous accueillons pratiquement
à parité :
45 % de femmes athlètes
et, donc, 55 % d'hommes.
-La sprinteuse Carolle Zahi
fait partie
de cette génération de femmes.
-Bonjour, sergent.
-Bonjour, mon général.
-Content de vous trouver là.
-A 29 ans, cette spécialiste
du 100 m et du 200 m
reprend progressivement
ses marques sur la piste,
après un congé maternité.
-C'est vrai que j'avais
une petite crainte, au départ,
à l'idée de devoir annoncer
que j'étais enceinte,
par rapport à ce qu'on a pu entendre
sur les médias, récemment.
Au contraire,
ça a été très bien accueilli.
Jusqu'à maintenant,
je suis toujours accompagnée
et soutenue,
surtout humainement.
-Avant d'intégrer
l'armée de champions en 2019,
Carolle a fait partie
du Pôle Espoir du CNSD.
C'est en tant que
sportive de haut niveau
de la Défense
qu'elle s'entraîne
pour les prochains JO
avec des rêves
de médaille,
notamment pour le relais 4 x 100.
-A Rio,
on se fait sortir en série.
A Tokyo,
on arrive en finale,
donc c'est déjà magnifique,
en fait.
L'objectif, à Paris,
ce serait de rentrer dans la boîte,
dans le podium : 1, 2, 3.
Pour moi,
cette échéance est particulière,
parce qu'elle est
à Paris.
En plus de ça, il y aura
les proches, la famille.
C'est sur cette échéance finale
que je vais m'arrêter.
-Pour partir à l'assaut
du mont Olympe,
Carolle va devoir
se confronter à elle-même :
appréhender son nouveau corps,
balayer ses doutes.
-Parfois,
les douleurs sont revenues,
parce que, en fait,
dans mon cerveau,
j'ai toujours intégré,
on va dire,
la technique de course
et tout ce qui s'ensuit,
par contre,
le corps réagit différemment.
Au départ, ça n'a pas été facile
de jongler entre mes intentions
et la façon
dont mon corps va interagir,
mais en fin de compte,
au bout de quelques mois,
on a réussi
à rééquilibrer la balance
et ça va beaucoup mieux.
Pour moi, l'athlétisme
et le sport en général,
c'est à 90 % du mental,
par rapport au physique.
Il faut jamais
laisser tomber
dans les moments
les plus difficiles.
Au contraire.
C'est sur le mental
que notre victoire se prépare.
-Le mardi, au lieu de faire
des séances courtes,
on fera des parcours mi-longs
et on finira par un long.
Elle a cette facilité
de réponse à l'entraînement
qui nous permet
d'avancer assez vite.
Là, en ce moment,
techniquement, ça va.
Techniquement, ça va.
En termes de vitesse, ça va,
comme je lui disais à l'instant.
Ce qui reste à travailler
et qui, à mon avis, est assez...
On a pas mal de retard
sur la partie résistance.
-Pour être capable à nouveau
de faire
des efforts longs et intenses,
la machine est lancée.
Carolle part en reconquête.
Musique légère
Elle aussi a des choses à prouver.
Sthélyne Grosy, 21 ans,
est une nouvelle pépite
de la boxe française.
Nous la retrouvons
dans un lieu bien connu
de l'élite
des sportifs hexagonaux :
l'Institut national du sport,
de l'expertise
et de la performance,
plus connu
sous l'acronyme INSEP.
28 ha au coeur du bois de Vincennes
dédiés à la réussite.
-Je vis à l'INSEP.
Je dors à l'INSEP.
Je mange à l'INSEP.
J'y ai mes entraînements.
J'y ai mes rendez-vous médicaux.
C'est vraiment, ici,
ma petite bulle, mon petit chez-moi.
C'est important d'avoir ce confort
et sa propre chambre,
où on peut se retrouver
lorsqu'on en a besoin.
C'est important.
-En parallèle
de ses entraînements biquotidiens,
Sthélyne étudie en 3e année
de licence STAPS,
option management
du sport.
La boxe anglaise
fait partie de sa vie
depuis l'âge de 7 ans
et elle est bien consciente
de la nécessité
de se construire un après.
Le haut niveau
est éphémère, cruel parfois.
Elle sort
tout juste
d'une blessure au dos.
-Les JO approchent.
Les blessures, forcément,
on va en croiser.
C'est tomber pour mieux se relever.
Je le prends un peu comme ça.
Ca me donne encore plus
de détermination et d'envie
pour arriver à mes objectifs.
La vie n'est pas facile.
Rien n'est facile.
Il faut travailler d'arrache-pied
pour obtenir ce qu'on souhaite.
-La boxeuse retrouve
peu à peu sa hargne.
Un combat intérieur
qu'elle entend gagner.
-2, 1...
Là, on y va ! Allez !
On ne réfléchit plus.
On doit monter.
Je suis dans le coin.
Je vous ai demandé de monter.
Allez !
Au-dessus de 100.
-La jeune Martiniquaise veut avoir
le droit de poursuivre son rêve
dans la catégorie des moins
de 57 kg, les poids plumes.
C'est les poings serrés
qu'elle se concentre
sur ses objectifs.
-Le staff médical a dit quoi ?
Quand est-ce que tu peux commencer
à reprendre les gants ?
-Pour l'instant, c'est fin juin,
pour reprendre le ring.
-Pour l'accompagner dans ce projet,
Sthélyne peut compter sur le soutien
de l'armée de champions
qu'elle a intégrée
en tant qu'aviatrice
en novembre 2022.
-Le point financier
reste important,
parce qu'on peut se projeter
pour plus tard.
Ca peut nous apporter sur...
La reconversion.
C'est...
Demain, si on souhaite rester
dans l'armée,
on a cette porte d'ouverte.
Ca nous apprend à vivre
comme des adultes, en fait.
On a une entrée d'argent.
On a un salaire.
-Le principal problème,
quand on est sportif de haut niveau,
c'est de savoir comment
on va pouvoir payer ses factures
et comment on va être à l'aise
pour l'avenir.
Là, avec un statut
de sportif de haut niveau
de la Défense,
ils ont une solde tous les mois.
Du coup, ils peuvent subvenir
à leurs besoins.
-On n'est pas militaire
juste pour l'argent.
Si on a signé
pour être dans l'armée,
il faut savoir la représenter
de temps en temps,
apporter ce qu'on sait
aux autres.
Je l'ai pas choisie
juste pour le plan financier.
Je l'ai choisie
pour m'impliquer,
pas entièrement,
car il y a le sport à côté,
mais dès que je peux,
s'il y a une initiation
et que je peux représenter
le bataillon de Joinville,
j'y vais.
Je vous présente Moreno Fendero.
C'est lui. C'est lui.
C'est grâce à lui.
Fais ça. Fais ça.
Sur mon choix d'être militaire
au sein du bataillon de Joinville,
c'est en partie grâce à Moreno.
C'est à Moreno
que j'ai pu poser mes questions.
"Comment ça se passe dans l'armée ?
Qu'est-ce que ça t'apporte ?
"Comment on l'intègre ?"
Et puis, le voir sur les photos,
sur les réseaux sociaux,
ça aide aussi.
Au niveau des réseaux,
voir qu'il passe ces moments
avec l'armée, forcément,
ça donne envie.
-Ils sont
quatre pugilistes militaires
de haut niveau,
le résultat
d'une longue histoire
entre la boxe
et le ministère des Armées,
marquée par
un profond respect mutuel.
A quelques centaines
de kilomètres
de là,
au pays des flamants roses,
de la pêche en bord de mer
et où, paraît-il,
le temps dure longtemps,
sauf peut-être
pour les amoureux de vitesse,
les matelots Axel et Poema
retrouvent
leurs peintures de guerre.
A Hyères,
sur la plage de l'Almanarre,
connue dans le monde entier
pour ses vents propices à la glisse,
ils retrouvent leurs sensations
après une semaine
de compétition internationale.
Musique trip-hop
Tous deux issus
de familles passionnées
de voile,
ils découvrent le kitesurf
adolescents.
Ils font partie
des meilleurs mondiaux
et ont rajouté un foil
à leur discipline.
-On est accroché
à une espèce de cerf-volant
qu'on appelle une aile de kite,
qu'on dirige avec une barre.
Cette barre est accrochée au kite
par des lignes.
On a une planche
comme une planche de wake,
où on met nos pieds.
Avec la force du vent
et le mouvement du kite,
ça nous fait glisser
sur l'eau.
Le kite-foil,
on a la même chose,
sauf qu'à la place d'avoir
la planche rectangulaire plate,
on a une planche
et, en dessous,
un mât avec un avion accroché
qui nous permet
de survoler l'eau
et de ne pas toucher l'eau
quand on avance.
-Fais un virement !
-En compétition,
ils évoluent
entre 30 et 35 noeuds,
soit environ 65 km/h,
parfois 80 à l'entraînement.
Leur sport est un sport à risque,
un sport extrême.
-On évolue dans un milieu
qui est sauvage.
C'est un milieu naturel,
la mer,
qu'on ne connaît pas forcément,
donc il faut être attentif
aux conditions météorologiques,
parce qu'on dépend de ça.
Si le vent monte ou baisse,
il faut adapter notre matériel
par rapport à ça.
Il faut garder une certaine humilité
par rapport à la nature.
Souvent, on se croit
un peu plus fort.
Des fois,
elle nous remet bien en place.
-Tu peux essayer de partir
un petit peu plus tard
que Poema.
-Ca veut dire que
je vais moins vite que lui ?
-Après, on échange.
Rires
Musique rock
...
-En 2024, le kite-foil fera
son entrée aux JO
pour la première fois.
Tous le savent :
les places seront chères.
...
-On est sous observation
pendant plusieurs épreuves.
A la fin, ils ne choisiront
qu'un Français et qu'une Française
pour aller représenter la France
aux Jeux Olympiques.
Pour la voile en général,
il n'y aura qu'un bateau par nation.
Durant cette période,
l'objectif est juste
de donner le meilleur
de nous-mêmes
et d'arriver
au meilleur niveau
possible.
-Si, aujourd'hui,
on est aussi bien représentés
dans le top 10 français,
c'est parce qu'on sait
travailler ensemble.
C'est ça qui nous permet
de nous dépasser,
parce qu'on a besoin,
en fait,
d'être entourés pour s'entraîner.
S'entraîner tout seul,
de son côté,
ça peut par moments être bénéfique,
mais le jour J, on sera 30
sur la ligne de départ.
Il faut savoir naviguer
au milieu des autres.
C'est un peu notre force,
aujourd'hui.
-Axel, c'est quelqu'un
qui ne renonce jamais
à aller s'entraîner,
qui est hyper stable
dans sa planification.
C'est un laborieux.
Il aime aller au combat,
travailler, s'entraîner.
Je peux même dire que,
quand il était petit,
il était hyperactif.
Il avait besoin
de faire du sport
tous les jours.
Ca se ressent dans son style de vie,
aussi sur ses performances,
car il est très stable.
C'est le plus stable de la régate.
C'est ce qui fait que,
à la fin, il gagne souvent.
Et puis, son engagement.
Il a besoin d'adrénaline,
de repousser ses limites,
ce qui est un petit peu
le cas de Poema aussi.
Poema, elle aime bien...
Quand elle se met en mode guerrière,
elle va vite, elle déchire tout.
Elle n'a pas peur
de prendre des risques.
C'est vraiment une force
qu'elle a,
surtout chez les filles.
-Un mental qu'ils construisent
avec l'armée.
Pour Axel, l'uniforme a été obtenu
à force de persévérance.
-L'intégration
à l'armée de champions,
au bataillon de Joinville,
a été pas facile pour moi.
J'ai fait ma demande,
déjà, depuis 2016.
Il y avait vraiment
une motivation
qui m'habitait pour faire partie
de cette aventure.
Voilà.
Je suis rentré en mai 2022.
J'ai fait mon processus
d'intégration
comme un militaire normal.
Ensuite, j'ai intégré
le bataillon de Joinville,
à Fontainebleau,
pour faire
mon acculturation militaire.
-Je vous ai mis un petit mot
sur la prépa physique.
Première phase de régénérescence.
Après, se remettre un peu dedans
avant la régate,
pour essayer de reprendre les bases
de ce que vous avez stabilisé
durant la planif' de l'hiver.
-Surtout, pas oublier
de... manger !
Ils rient.
-La professionnalisation
du kitesurf
a changé la préparation
des athlètes.
Si, avant, savoir naviguer vite
et intelligemment suffisait,
maintenant,
ils doivent intégrer
une préparation mentale
et physique.
Pour gratter des centièmes,
prendre du poids de façon saine
est aussi devenu un objectif.
-Nous, dans notre sport,
il y a un intérêt
à être lourd.
On s'en est rendu compte
au fil des années,
parce que, dans notre sport,
en fait,
on doit choisir
une taille d'aile, de kite,
de cerf-volant,
comme on peut dire.
Plus on va prendre une aile
qui est grande,
plus on va aller vite,
donc notre stratégie,
c'est, si on peut,
de tenir la plus grande
surface d'aile possible,
ce qui va nous donner
énormément de puissance.
Si on arrive à contrôler ça
pour aller plus vite,
on peut gagner notre compétition.
-Sur ce chemin escarpé
vers la victoire,
chaque soutien compte
pour dépasser ses peurs
et continuer à avancer.
Une motivation supplémentaire,
c'est peut-être
ce qu'est venue chercher Mona
dans le sud-ouest de la France,
à Agen,
au 48e régiment de transmissions.
-Je vous laisse
lire votre rôle
et je vais lire le mien.
Voilà. Allez-y.
-"Le rôle du parrain."
C'est moi.
-Ou de la marraine.
-"Donner une image valorisante
de lui-même, de l'institution..."
-Devant des lycéens
et des représentants
d'associations sportives,
elle s'engage
à faire rayonner l'unité
et à lui faire découvrir
son nouveau monde.
-"Le rôle du commandant
de la formation parrainée",
donc le 48e régiment
de transmissions,
"est d'établir un contact privilégié
avec le parrain..."
Expliquez-nous.
-Ce partenariat débute
avec la présentation
de son équipement.
-Quand je pars à vélo,
j'ai 20 km.
Le vélo, c'est ça.
C'est un handbike.
-Dans sa catégorie,
Mona doit enchaîner
750 m de natation,
20 km
de handbike
et 5 km en fauteuil de course.
-A l'entraînement,
tu es comme les autres,
sur la route ?
-Ouais. Je mets un drapeau.
-C'est plus simple ?
-Celle qui participera au relais
de la flamme olympique
partage son goût
de l'effort
avec des hommes en armes
qui comprennent son engagement.
-On a déjà
défini quelques actions
auxquelles je pourrai participer,
des journées portes ouvertes, etc.
Ca va être chouette
de pouvoir les rencontrer,
de faire encore
plus ample connaissance
avec les gens qui travaillent ici
au quotidien, ce qu'ils font.
Eux aussi
vont pouvoir apprendre
à me connaître, au-delà
de la sportive de haut niveau.
Et puis, je vais pouvoir
éventuellement
parler un peu de mon sport,
faire en sorte d'animer tout ça
et de les emmener avec moi
dans mon projet
de Jeux Paralympiques
pour Paris en 2024.
-Ce sera un soutien moral.
Elle va se préparer physiquement.
Pour revenir sur elle,
ce qui m'a frappé aussi,
c'est sa manière
d'aborder la compétition,
qui est assez différente de celle
d'une compétitrice ordinaire.
Quand on est parathlète,
on se bat avant tout
contre soi-même.
C'est ça qui est assez beau
et qui a beaucoup de sens
pour nous, ici.
C'est un message
qui sera assez fort
à passer
à tous les militaires
qui ont besoin
de se surpasser eux-mêmes
et pas de faire la compétition
avec leurs voisins.
Musique militaire
Applaudissements
-A Brive-la-Gaillarde,
en Corrèze,
la compétition sera bien présente.
Près de 200 athlètes
représentant 21 nations
se sont donné rendez-vous
pour un choc sportif de haut niveau.
*-Je déclare ouvert
le 24e championnat du monde
militaire
de triathlon
de Brive-la-Gaillarde.
-Sur le papier,
l'équipe militaire tricolore
fait partie
des favorites.
Un statut que les Français
vont devoir assumer
sur les différentes épreuves.
Dans la catégorie Elite,
les concurrents vont s'affronter
sur un format olympique.
En entrée,
1500 m de natation
dans une eau à 16 degrés.
Vient ensuite le plat de résistance
avec 40 km de vélo.
En dessert,
10 km de course à pied.
Les filles ouvrent les hostilités.
5 Françaises sont en lice,
dont deux soeurs et deux membres
de l'armée de champions,
le maréchal des logis-chef
Audrey Merle
et le sergent Sandra Dodet.
Coup de feu
Rapidement,
la Française Mathilde Gautier
prend les rênes de la course
et sort en tête
de chaque épreuve.
Applaudissements
...
Derrière,
la compétition est rude.
-Allez, hein !
...
Encouragements
-Impériale
et seule en tête,
le soldat Mathilde Gautier
s'impose en 2h 12 min et 53 s,
juste devant Audrey et Sandra,
qui viennent compléter le podium
après une incroyable remontada.
...
-A un moment, je me suis dit
qu'on jouait pour la 4e place,
mais quand on a doublé
ma petite soeur,
j'ai eu en visu assez rapidement
les deux, finalement,
Paulina Klimas
et Zsanett Bragmayer.
Là, je pense que, toutes les deux,
on a eu un petit coup de boost,
en pensant que
c'était enfin possible.
-Après le triomphe des filles,
c'est au tour des garçons
de s'expliquer.
A ce jeu-là, le maréchal des logis
Le Corre est plutôt doué.
Champion du monde longue distance
2022 et sportif
de haut niveau de la Défense
depuis une décennie,
il compte bien entraîner
ses frères d'armes
dans son sillage.
Dès la sortie d'eau,
les Français sont aux avant-postes.
-Allez, Jérem ! C'est bien !
Allez, allez !
-A la 2e transition,
quatre tricolores font partie
du groupe de tête.
Encouragements
...
A pied,
Pierre Le Corre rattrape
son léger retard et finit la course
aux côtés de son compatriote,
le soldat Nathan Lessmann,
avant de faire la différence
avec 15 secondes
d'avance.
Une course quasi parfaite.
-Pierre, il est
très, très intelligent
dans sa gestion
de course
et dans la lecture
de course.
Au niveau stratégique,
il sait très bien le moment
où il faut attaquer,
le moment où il faut essayer
de se reposer.
Il analyse très bien.
C'est un très gros point fort.
-C'est un athlète
que j'admire à la fois
pour sa force mentale,
psychique,
son exceptionnalité physique,
son élégance et son humilité.
C'est un vrai Ironman militaire.
C'est un vrai soldat.
-Le lendemain,
les jambes sont encore lourdes.
Pas assez pour entamer
la détermination
des relayeurs français.
Nathan ouvre le bal,
avec des Hongrois et des Suisses
prêts à en découdre.
Après Célia vient
le tour de Pierre.
-Pour Pierre Le Corre,
actuellement,
on est exactement à...
A 30...
35 secondes sur les Suisses.
C'est eux qui nous inquiètent.
Pierre va se retrouver tout seul
à faire le vélo.
On va faire un mano à mano
avec les Suisses
et on verra ensuite.
...
-Le couteau entre les dents !
Allez, tu vas la chercher !
...
Tu vas la chercher !
-A la fin, c'est toujours
la France qui gagne.
...
Dans la course comme au quotidien,
les quatre chercheurs d'or
ont pu s'appuyer
sur leur solide famille militaire.
-C'est un soutien sans faille.
Moi, en plus...
Je le dis pas souvent,
mais vu que j'ai l'occasion
de le faire...
Ca fait trois ans que je suis remise
de la maladie de Lyme.
L'armée m'a pas lâchée
pendant les quatre ans
où j'étais au fond du trou,
alors que j'ai perdu
beaucoup de sponsors.
C'est grâce à eux
que j'ai pu revenir à ce niveau.
-En organisant ce championnat,
la France assume
son statut de pilier
du Conseil international
du sport militaire,
mais pas seulement.
-Je suis satisfait,
aussi parce que
ces épreuves ont permis
à nos champions
de s'entraîner,
peut-être pas au plus haut niveau,
mais à un très, très bon niveau,
en vue aussi pour eux,
à titre français,
de préparer les échéances de Paris
dans un an.
-L'idée est d'identifier
ce qui n'a pas marché,
ce qui a marché,
et d'avancer comme ça
pour essayer
d'arriver à une course
plus ou moins parfaite
le jour où on l'attendra.
C'est comme ça qu'on avance.
C'est des passages importants
et obligatoires pour progresser.
Acclamations
-Pour Audrey,
Sandra et Pierre,
Brive est une première étape.
Ils devront encore avaler
de très nombreux kilomètres
à la nage, à vélo ou à pied,
afin d'atteindre Paris en 2024.
-Un grand bravo
à toute l'équipe de France,
parce qu'on n'a rien lâché.
C'était une superbe...
Un superbe événement.
Voilà. On part tous
avec de très beaux souvenirs.
Musique douce
-Au revoir !
-Les athlètes
que nous avons rencontrés
rêvent de marquer l'histoire
de leur sport.
En intégrant l'armée,
ils ont rejoint un groupe soudé
autour d'un même objectif olympique,
un projet fou,
le projet d'une vie.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...